- ALL RIGHT, RANGERS,
WE HAVE GOT A PROBLEM.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS IS?
- [sniffs]
HMM. 2009 BAJA RED.
PLAYFUL ON THE NOSE,
VERY DRY ON THE PALATE,
HINTS OF EUCALYPTUS,
STONE FRUITS,
AND KALAMATA OLIVES.
- WHAT?
NO, IT'S MARIJUANA.
GOD,
I FIGURED IF ANYONE
WOULD KNOW,
IT WOULD BE YOU, DENZEL.
- WHY?
BECAUSE ALL BLACK MEN LOVE WEED?
- NO, BECAUSE YOU LOVE WEED.
LOOK AT YOUR SHIRT.
- HO, THAT'S RIGHT!
WHO DON'T LIKE SMOKIN' UP?
- UH, I DON'T BECAUSE I'M NOT
IN THE SIXTH GRADE,
AND I HAVE SHIT TO DO.
- I CONFISCATED THIS
FROM A DIRTY HIPPIE
50 FEET
FROM THIS RANGER STATION.
WHO'S GOT AN IDEA
FOR HOW TO SMOKE OUT
THESE DOPE GROWIN'
DRAFT DODGERS?
COME ON, GUYS,
GET CREATIVE.
- I KNOW HOW WE CAN GET
SOME INSPIRATION.
♪
- DUDE. DUDE. DUDE.
WE HAVE TO BUILD A ROCKET...
- [inhales]
- TO SPY ON THE HIPPIES
FROM OUTER SPACE, MAN.
- YEAH!
BUT THE ROCKET'S GOTTA BE SHAPED
LIKE A BIG, HAIRY DINOSAUR DICK!
- [gasps] WITH GIANT, PURPLE
PTERODACTYL WINGS.
- A HAIRY DINOSAUR DICK
WITH WINGS?
THAT IS BRILLIANT!
WE'LL SWOOP DOWN
AND LASER GUN
THE BASTARDS!
- YEAH!
- THAT'S IT!
- I LOVE WEED.
- CONNIE! CALL NASA.
WE NEED
A JURASSIC [bleep] ROCKET
AND A SHITLOAD
MORE FUNYUNS.
- WE'RE DEAD.
I CAN'T FEEL MY FACE.
I THINK WE'RE DEAD.
I'VE GOT BUGS ALL OVER ME!
[groans]